Mais de l'intérieur, je suis très anglaise et tout le monde m'exaspère.
(Rires)
C'est vrai.
Ma famille est arabe du Yémen
et je savais que traverser ce détroit,
celui de Bab-el-Mandeb,
n'est pas un grand exploit.
Je me posais constamment cette question simple :
si les ancêtres des singes d'Amérique ont pu traverser l'océan Atlantique,
pourquoi les hominidés n'ont-ils pas pu traverser cette petite étendue d'eau ?
Mais le Yémen,
en comparaison avec l'Europe par exemple,
était si peu étudié
qu'on aurait pu le comparer à un territoire presque vierge.
En plus de son emplacement, c'est ce qui a rendu son potentiel de découverte
si prometteur
et j'avais tellement de questions.
Quand avons-nous commencé à traverser Bab-el-Mandeb ?
Et aussi, quelles espèces d'hominidés à part nous étaient arrivées au Yémen ?
Pourrions-nous trouver une espèce encore inconnue de la science ?
Il s'est avéré que je n'étais pas la seule à avoir remarqué le potentiel du Yémen.
Il y avait en fait quelques universitaires là-bas.
Hélas, à cause de l'instabilité politique, ils sont partis et je suis arrivée.
Je cherchais des grottes :
des grottes car elles étaient les premiers biens immobiliers.
Mais également car si vous cherchez des fossiles sous cette chaleur,
une grotte sera toujours le meilleur endroit pour en trouver un bien préservé.
Mais la situation du Yémen a pris une très mauvaise tournure
et quelques jours avant que je ne m'envole pour le Yémen,
la guerre civile a dégénéré en conflit régional,
l'aéroport de la capitale a été bombardé
et le Yémen est devenu une zone d'exclusion aérienne.
Mes parents ont pris cette décision avant ma naissance :
je naîtrais Anglaise.
Je n'avais rien à voir avec la meilleure décision de ma vie.
Et maintenant...
Les chanceux de ma famille se sont enfuis
et les autres, ils se font bombarder
et envoient des messages à vous faire détester votre propre existence.
Cette guerre a lieu depuis quatre ans.
Elle a lieu depuis plus de quatre ans et a conduit à une crise humanitaire.
Il y a une famine,
une famine créée par les humains.
C'est une famine créée par les humains, pas une famine naturelle,
une famine créée par les humains et l'ONU a prévenu
qu'elle pourrait être la pire famine que le monde ait connue en cent ans.
Cette guerre m'a montré plus clairement que jamais
qu'aucun lieu, qu'aucun peuple ne mérite d'être laissé pour compte.
J'ai donc rejoint d'autres équipes et j'ai collaboré avec elles
dans d'autres régions instables.
Mais je voulais désespérément retourner au Yémen,
car pour moi, le Yémen, c'est une affaire personnelle.
J'ai continué à réfléchir à un projet que je pourrais réaliser au Yémen
qui aiderait à mettre en lumière ce qu'il s'y passait.
Toutes les idées que j'avais échouaient
ou les risques étaient trop élevés, car soyons honnêtes,
la majeure partie du Yémen est trop dangereuse pour une équipe occidentale.
Mais on m'a alors dit qu'à Socotra, une île du Yémen,
on était en sécurité, une fois qu'on l'avait atteinte.
Il s'est avéré que quelques universitaires yéménites et internationaux
y travaillaient encore.
Cela m'a vraiment enthousiasmée,
parce que regardez la proximité de Socotra avec l'Afrique.
Et pourtant nous ne savons pas quand les humains sont arrivés sur cette île.
Mais Socotra, pour ceux qui connaissent,
vous la connaissez probablement pour une tout autre raison.
Vous la connaissez sans doute comme les Galapagos de l'océan Indien,
car c'est l'un des endroits les plus riches en biodiversité sur cette Terre.
Mais nous recevions aussi des informations
indiquant que cet environnement incroyablement fragile et son peuple
étaient menacés
car ils étaient en première ligne des conflits au Moyen-Orient
et du changement climatique.
Et peu à peu, j'ai réalisé que Socotra était mon projet au Yémen.
J'ai voulu réunir une grande équipe multidisciplinaire.
Nous voulions traverser l'archipel à pied, à dos de chameau et en boutre
pour faire l'état des lieux de l'île.
Cela n'avait été tenté qu'une seule fois auparavant, en 1999.
Mais ce n'est pas quelque chose de facile à réaliser.
Nous avions terriblement besoin d'une mission de reconnaissance.
D'une étude de terrain.
Je dis souvent qu'une grande expédition sans mission de reconnaissance,
c'est comme un premier rendez-vous sans avoir espionné la personne sur Facebook.
(Rires)
C'est faisable, mais est-ce judicieux ?
Il y en a trop qui savent dans cette salle.
Notre équipe de reconnaissance
était heureusement habituée aux régions instables,
ce qui est plutôt important
car nous cherchions à nous rendre entre le Yémen et la Somalie.
Après avoir demandé ce qui nous a semblé un million de faveurs,
y compris de la part du sous-gouverneur,
nous nous sommes enfin mis en marche,
sur un cargo cimentier en bois
voguant sur des eaux infestées de pirates au milieu de l'océan Indien
avec ceci pour toilettes.
(Rires)
Vous voyez ça ?
Vous connaissez la pire expérience que vous pouvez avoir aux toilettes ?
Je n'avais jamais nagé avec des dauphins auparavant,
je leur ai fait directement caca dessus.
(Rires)
J'ai aussi vraiment découvert que je suis moins stressée
par des eaux infestées de pirates
que par une invasion de cafards
si nombreux
qu'à un moment je suis allée sur le pont inférieur
et le sol était noir et mouvant.
(Gémissements du public)
La nuit, il n'y avait que trois plateformes surélevées pour dormir
mais il y avait seulement – nous étions quatre membres dans l'équipe.
Si vous aviez une plateforme surélevée pour dormir,
vous n'étiez aux prises qu'avec quelques cafards durant la nuit
alors que si vous étiez sur le pont, bon courage à vous.
J'étais la seule fille de l'équipe et pendant tout le voyage,
je m'en suis sortie sans dormir sur le pont.
Et puis la quatrième ou la cinquième nuit :
Martin Edström m'a regardé et a dit : « Ella, Ella, je crois en l'égalité. »
(Rires)
Nous avons voyagé sur ce cargo cimentier pendant trois jours
puis nous avons commencé à voir la terre.
Après trois ans d'échecs,
je voyais enfin le Yémen.
Il n'y a pas de sensation comparable au début d'une expédition.
C'est le moment où vous sautez d'une jeep
ou que vous levez les yeux depuis un bateau
et vous savez qu'il y a la possibilité,
faible mais réelle,
que vous trouviez quelque chose
qui puisse s'ajouter ou changer ce que nous savons
sur qui nous sommes et d'où nous venons.
Il n'y a pas de sensation comparable
et c'est une sensation que tellement de scientifiques ressentent,
mais rarement dans des lieux politiquement instables.
Car les scientifiques occidentaux sont dissuadés ou ont l'interdiction
de travailler dans des régions instables.
Mais voici le problème :
certains scientifiques se spécialisent dans l'étude de la jungle,
d'autres travaillent dans des systèmes de cavités profondes,
d'autres encore montent dans des fusées et s'envolent vers l'espace.
Mais, apparemment, travailler dans une région instable
est jugé trop risqué.
C'est complètement arbitraire.
Qui ici n'a pas grandi en entendant des récits d'aventures ?
La plupart de nos héros étaient des scientifiques et des universitaires.
La science, c'était partir vers l'inconnu.
C'était l'exploration planétaire, même s'il y avait des risques.
Quand est-il devenu acceptable d'interdire la science
dans les régions instables ?
Je ne dis pas que tous les scientifiques devraient aller
travailler dans des régions instables.
Ce n'est pas un appel enthousiaste et naïf.
Mais voilà :
pour ceux qui ont conduit des recherches, qui suivent le protocole de sécurité
et sont entraînés,
arrêtez de stopper les personnes motivées.
De plus,
si la guerre fait rage dans seulement une partie du pays
tout le pays n'est pas forcément concerné.
Je ne dis pas que nous devrions aller dans des zones de guerre.
Mais le Kurdistan irakien est très différent de Falloujah.
Quelques mois après mon échec à entrer au Yémen,
une autre équipe m'a adoptée.
L'équipe du professeur Grame Barker travaillait au Kurdistan irakien
où ils exploraient la grotte de Shanidar.
Quelques décennies auparavant, la grotte de Shanidar
avait révélé un homme de Néandertal connu sous le nom de Shanidar I.
Pour une série télévisée de la BBC et PBS, nous avons redonné vie à Shanidar I
et je veux vous faire rencontrer Ned, l'homme de Néandertal.
Et voici le truc le plus cool à propos de Ned.
Ned, ce gars-là,
vous le rencontrez avant qu'il soit blessé.
Il s'avère que Ned était gravement handicapé.
Il était tellement handicapé qu'il ne peut avoir survécu
que grâce à l'aide d'autres hommes de Néandertal.
C'était la preuve que,
au moins pour cette population d'hommes de Néandertal de cette époque,
les hommes de Néandertal étaient comme nous
et prenaient parfois soin de ceux qui ne pouvaient pas être autonomes.
Ned est un homme de Néandertal irakien.
Que nous manque-t-il d'autre ?
Quelles autres formidables découvertes scientifiques
ne faisons-nous pas car nous ne cherchons pas ?
D'ailleurs, ces régions méritent des récits empreints d'espoir
et la science et la recherche peuvent y participer.
J'avancerais qu'elles peuvent aider le développement de façon tangible
car ces découvertes deviennent une grande source de fierté locale.
C'est la seconde raison pour laquelle la recherche a un problème de géographie.
Nous ne donnons pas les moyens aux universitaires locaux, n'est-ce pas ?
Cela ne m'a pas échappé
que dans le domaine en particulier de la paléoanthropologie,
nous étudions les origines humaines,
bien que nous ayons si peu de scientifiques d'origines différentes.
Et pourtant, ces régions sont remplies d'étudiants et d'universitaires
qui veulent désespérément travailler avec nous
et en vérité,
pour eux,
il y a moins de problèmes de sécurité que pour nous.
Nous oublions toujours que, pour eux, ce n'est pas un environnement hostile,
c'est chez eux.
Je vous le dis,
les recherches réalisées dans des régions instables avec des collaborateurs locaux
peuvent mener à des découvertes incroyables
et c'est ce que nous espérons plus que tout accomplir à Socotra.
On dit de Socotra
que c'est le lieu le plus exotique sur Terre.
Leon McCarron, Rhys Thwaites-Jones, Martin Edström et moi-même l'avons remarqué.
Regardez cet endroit.
Ces endroits ne sont pas des bouges, ils ne sont pas à abandonner,
ils sont la pointe de la science et de la recherche du futur.
90% des reptiles de cette île et
37% de ses espèces végétales n'existent nulle part ailleurs sur Terre,
y compris cette espèce de Dragonnier de Socotra
dont on extrait une résine rouge.
Il y a autre chose.
Les gens sur Socotra, certains vivent encore dans des grottes,
et c'est passionnant
car si une grotte y est un logement prisé à notre siècle,
ce l'était peut-être il y a des milliers d'années.
Mais nous avons besoin de données pour le prouver, de fossiles, d'outils en pierre.
Alors notre équipe de reconnaissance a fait équipe avec d'autres scientifiques,
des anthropologues et des chroniqueurs,
internationaux autant locaux, comme Ahmed Alarqbi,
et nous voulons désespérément faire connaître cet endroit
avant qu'il ne soit trop tard.
Maintenant, nous devons trouver comment y retourner
pour cette grande expédition
car la recherche,
la recherche a un problème de géographie.
Vous avez été un public adorable.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)